et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
le maire de béziers envers ménard
bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
julien lécuyer de la voix du nord
bonjour julien bonjour oriane bonjour
monsieur ménard dont on va parler de la
campagne on commence évidemment par
cette guerre en ukraine 15e jour de
guerre en ukraine aujourd'hui robert
ménard et on a vu hier ses frappes russe
qui vont toujours plus loin dans
l'horreur puisque c'est un hôpital
pédiatrique qui a été touché j'ai vu ça
dans la ville de marioupol est-ce qu'on
peut encore arrêté de la dîmière poutine
dans son escalade selon vous j'en sais
rien honnêtement je suis pas au coeur
des discussions diplomatiques
ce que je constate c'est qu'on a un chef
de l'état qui fait le job moi je
critique monsieur monsieur macro est pas
là dessus d'abord on se doit d'être
derrière lui il me semble que c'était
une espèce de de bonne pratique de la
politique que certains clients nationale
attendait bien sûr on peut pas dire à la
fois qu en ukraine se joue au delà
attendait de la liberté de
l'indépendance de la démocratie dans un
pays se joue quelque chose pour
l'ensemble de l'europe et puis dire non
on va continuer à débattre moi j'ai pas
envie d'affaiblir le chef de l'état qui
mènent des discussions dans le même cas
ce discours elle a dit notamment dans le
gard pas loin de chez vous que
elle m'a conserver un peu de la crise
n'ont attendu non mais moi je ne suis
pas d'accord avec tout ce que dit marine
le pen je suis ni son fan club ni membre
de son parti je la soutiens par pourrait
certain nombre de réseaux sur sa tombe
de questions mais pas sur tout mais vous
le dites il faut arrêter d'attaquer le
chef de l'état je lui ai enlevé je le
lui ai dit c'est pas que je vous dis ici
c'est que je lui ai dit je lui dis
aujourd'hui on rend pas service à notre
pays est quand même quand on fait de la
politique normalement on l'a fait pour
son pays on l'a fini pour soi même ni
pour son parti donc ils mènent des
discussions
enfin on peut pas lui reprocher de ne
pas avoir tout fait pour éviter la
guerre alors évidemment c'est pas un
succès ma faim qu'ils pouvaient savoir
que ce serait un succès ou pas et par
ailleurs je constate avec bonheur que
l'europe pour une fois vous savez ce
fait entendre prince et à terme de
mesures tape du poing sur la table c'est
à dire en gros l'europe dont on rêvait
l'europe dottore veste et nantes forte
une europe qui soit capable de peser sur
la centrale ont nagé le sentiment
qu'elle est en train de naître je vais
pas me dire non comme c'est le fait de
d'un opposant politique c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle c'est une bonne nouvelle
ces pays monsieur ménard justement par
rapport à cette position européenne que
que vous avez alors il ya le sommet en
plus des 27 aujourd'hui et demain est-ce
que ça n'oblige pas à faire une sorte de
aussi de mea culpa sur la manière dont
on a traité l'europe comme si elle était
la pestiférée qu'il ne fallait voir que
les intérêts de la de la france est-ce
que ça oblige pas finalement regard de
la crise à revoir les paradigmes ah oui
moi je pense qu'un certain nombre de mes
amis politiques du camp de mon cas avec
des guillemets doit se poser cette
question là moi j'ai toujours été
contrairement à eux pro européens ce qui
me valait d'ailleurs des problèmes avec
les uns et les autres parce que je pense
que peut-être parce que je j'ai passé ma
vie dans le monde entier que je sais que
la france est un grand pays important
dans la voix compte mais aujourd'hui
étant économiquement ce que nous sommes
on a besoin pour peser sur la sentra
seul et c'est important de donner sur
ces notations de plus de poids d'une
importance peut de plus grande or quelle
autre cadre on peut avoir que le rampe
alors c'est vrai que je fais une
différence entre la bureaucratie
bruxelloise mais et l'europe lithiques
cons et qu'on dit que j'espère qu'on est
en train de conserver cette crise elle
aura au moins servi à ça c'est à dire qu
on peut aujourd'hui être un peu à un
groupe de pays de 27 pays dont dont le
poids économique est important enfin la
plume la plus grosse puissance dans le
monde encore aujourd'hui quand on est
tous ensemble et dont le poids politique
pourrait devenir important si il ya un
aspect chasse même pas dire positif
parce que d'abord on a tous en tête les
images en ce moment donc je dis pas soi
mais s'il ya quelque chose qui pouvait
sortir d'importants ce serait ça et je
pense que oui vous avez raison il ya un
certain nombre de gens s'attendent de
mes amis encore une fois qui devrait se
reposer la question de leur regard sur
l'europe l'europe oui elle peut être
quelque chose d'insupportable
quand c'est une robe bureaucratique
tatillonne technocratique mais elle est
aussi la seule voix que la france pour
emprunter si elle veut continuer à peser
sur les affaires du monde comment
comment vous concevez un peu le regard
de votre territoire des gens que vous
rencontrez au jour le jour les
conséquences des des sanctions de
l'union européenne sur sur sur la russie
les conséquences en terme d'augmentation
des prix de l'énergie est ce que vous
craignez que ça en flammes finalement là
l'opinion publique écoutez je constate
deux choses qui me semble qu'ils peuvent
paraître paradoxal et qui me semble le
génie de ce pays la première c'est que
oui oui il ya une crête attendez moi je
suis dans une ville vous voyez enfin
baissier 80000 habitants tu te rends pas
le métro il n'y a pas de métro lé réseau
de transport en commun ils sont réduits
à peu de chose il faut savoir ce que
c'est et c'est la majorité la france qui
est comme ça donc c'est les jambes qui
pour venir travailler à béziers car ils
sont dans un village pardon mais il
traîne ma voiture en fait je suppose que
chez vous c'est pareil au toute la
nation
de vie moyenne vous pouvez pas leur
expliquer va faire tu vas prendre ton
vélo fin le tipi territoriaux n'est et
c'est vrai qu'il ya aujourd'hui en
termes de de risque de pouvoir lâcher un
vrai problème si pour nous 3 c'est pas
un problème de payer 30 euros de plus le
plein pour tout un tas de chance c'est
un vrai problème
attendez je sais pas je sais qu'il faut
prendre en compte ça je ne sais pas si
c'est qu'il faut bloquer les prix
aujourd'hui de de l'essence s'il faut
baisser les taxes ou faire une taxe
flottante il ya plusieurs autres choses
que je sais c'est que pour une partie de
la population il faut absolument
répondre à cette question parce que
toutes les errances voilà mais je pense
que le gouvernement va s'y employer dans
les jours qui viennent sur ça et en même
temps et c'est pour ça que je vous dis
que c'est absolument incroyable en même
temps les gens dont vous pourrez donc
vous pourriez vous dire attendez il
trouve que la guerre la guerre du
d'ukraine ça serait dû à sa pro séparés
c'est les premiers jeux nous on a pour
on a apporté déjà un certain nombre de
choses à la frontière à la frontière
entre la pologne et l'ukraine c'est les
premiers qui donne ces les premiers qui
vont acheter des produits qui les amène
pour qu on les distribue ses les
premiers qui nous écrivent pour recevoir
des femmes ivry je trouve que c'est ça
qui est formidable il faut le dire c'est
que les gens ils sont pas comme ça d'un
égoïsme tel qu'il dirait aux coutumes
bois l'ukraine
juste on va revenir sur cette question
des réfugiés parce qu'elle est
importante mais un dernier mot sur les
sanctions puisque ça fait partie aussi
du sommet de versailles est ce que pour
vous l'union européenne va bloquer les
importations de gaz russe aujourd'hui
écoutés quand tu es français n'a pas
beaucoup de mal à le dire site est
alimenté un peu plus de mal à le dire
c'est ça la réalité moi ça me choquerait
pas qu'on le fasse est ce qu'on ne peut
aujourd'hui le faire je n'en sais rien
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les sanctions
elles sont importantes sanctionné comme
on l'a fait non seulement les oligarques
qu'il faut sanctionner je rappelle que
50% de leurs avoirs de leurs richesses
pour parler en français de ce qu'ils
possèdent sont en europe donc les faux
nez et j'ai vu qu'on a rajouté encore un
certain nombre de noms il faut les
sanctionner mais il faut aussi
sanctionner l'état l'état russe ça aura
des conséquences néfastes sur nous mais
est-ce que c'est pas en partie par dont
le prix à payer est ce que tu peux te
mobilisés pour pour pour l'ukraine se
mobiliser pour la démocratie et te dire
j'aurais rien en retour à payer ça ne
coûtera rien je crois que ça c'est des
vues de l'esprit que la question des
réfugiés et se pose on a atteint les 2
millions de dhs et d'exilés et l'onu en
augure 2,2 de plus est-ce qu'il faut les
est ce qu'ils font en accueillir une
partie en france où est ce qu'il faut
comme le suggère eric zemmour finalement
les cantonais a obéi aux pays
limitrophes tels la pologne ou la
moldavie d'abord j'ai constaté qu eric
zemmour avait changé d'avis un petit peu
là dessus
je me moque je me moque d'abord il a
quand même un petit peu changé comme
pour quelqu'un qui ne devait jamais
changé ne devait jamais faire de la
politique comme les autres donc ne
jamais écouter l'opinion publique c'est
un peu raté voilà ça c'est un premier
mot vin bien sûr qu'il faut les
accueillir nous on a accueilli à ses
retombées gens il se fait que parce
qu'invisible auquel on en est à la
quatre voies regret la quatrième famille
a pas des tonnes de demandes mais il y
en a pas beaucoup moi aussi je connais
très bien la la je connais très bien je
connais assez bien là là là l'ukraine
parce que j'étais patron de reporters
sentais incapable
sachez qu'il y avait des gens disent
qu'ils ont été tuées assassinées en
ukraine et j'étais allé un certain
nombre de fois points défend donc j'ai
encore des liens ça s'est passé comme ça
c'est les gens qui me connaissaient qui
connaissait des gens qui me connaissent
comment voulez arriver à béziers c'est
comme ça et qui on demandait à venir
évidemment tu les accueille en fait
c'est le minimum presse à venir avait
fait un peu tout seul sans l'aide de
l'état les maires ne sont pas aidés
aujourd'hui par deux en attaque a fait
avant tout le monde avant même
l'association des maires de fond de moi
j'ai pas attendu de savoir ce que l'état
allait nous donner ou nous aider ou ce
que l'association des maires de france à
les faire ou pas faire enfin quand vous
avez un appel de jean qu'est-ce que vous
le redis dit attendez je vais réfléchir
cinq minutes avant oui vous êtes le
bienvenu on vous accueille on a mis à
disposition des locaux municipaux parce
qu il se fait qu'on a des lieux pour le
faire moi j'ai réquisitionné un certain
nombre de la mer peut réquisitionner un
certain nombre de logements vides on a
fait ça et on continuera à les acquérir
et parallèlement oui on a en a recueilli
tout le matériel dont on a besoin qu'on
a amené directement à la frontière entre
l'ukraine et la pologne ça c'est le
minimum qu'on doit faire le minimum
qu'on doit faire mais je ne sais pas
comment les choses vont évoluer vous
savez on était à s'attendre je sais pas
moi en tout cas je plaide coupable dans
ce terrain là à ne pas imaginer que
monsieur poutine allait passer aux actes
rappelez-vous enfin quand même la teneur
générale de la presse et des hommes
politiques c'était de dire il fait le
mariole il roule des mécaniques et quand
la cia qu'on brocarde facilement met-il
en garde a tonné c'est les américains
qui pousse au crime et au sûr sauf qu'il
a fait qu'il a fait et donc nous comme
maire je fais tout ce que je peux faire
et je continuerai à le faire et à
répondre présent à tous les appels qui
me seront adressées mais évidemment la
situation
elle se réglera pas ce niveau là
d'autant que c'est des gens qui nous
disent la première chose qui nous dit ce
monsieur et madame c'est nous on vous
retourner en ukraine et vous pétez
cyclable sur cette question de l'accueil
des réfugiés vous avez changé de
discours la turbine
oui oui bien sûr moi je me rappelle
quand j'ai été élu maire vous savez
quelques 2 3 ans après il ya eu la grave
crise mais la crise en syrie et on a
fait j'ai fait des déclarations le
journal municipal a fait d une
absolue de tout et que que je ne referai
plus pour tout vous dire que j'ai honte
d'avoir fait voilà pour vous dire les
choses quelle a été leur virement chez
vous qu'est ce qui vous a fait prendre
conscience justement de 7,7
mais peut-être le métier de maire il
vous apprend un espèce de pragmatisme
entre vous savez des gras grands
discours idéologique enfin vous
connaissez lille moi je connais assez
bien à lille le maire de lille de droite
de gauche et oui vous avez des choix
idéologiques mais vous savez aussi à
confronter à la population est
confrontée à cette population je me suis
aperçu que il y avait sept heures de
discours qui qui a qui rendait pas
compte de la réalité qui se casser le
nez sur sur les gens ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est à
leurs vis-à-vis de mes amis politiques
c'est l'irresponsabilité d'un certain
nombre d'entre eux pendant la crise
sanitaire c'est moi monsieur macron
c'est évidemment pas ma tasse de thé sur
les questions d'immigration de sécurité
ou que sais-je encore d'identité là je
pense qu'il fait les cinq ans qu'on
vient de passer ses 50 perdu dans ce
domaine là mais enfin que la réponse
qu'il apporte par exemple sur le pass
sanitaire c'est une réponse que j'ai je
trouvais judicieuse intelligente et je
me suis pas demandé ce qu'elle est en
penser les français avant de dire que
j'appuyais le chef de l'état j'essaie
d'être espèce de pragmatisme de bon sens
est pareil et je réponds à votre
question et pareil pour l'épauler pour
les peaux pour tout l'accueil des
réfugiés en plus pardon mais c'était
pendant 25 ans ma vie et qui plus est
celle de ma femme qui est lilloise je
vous disais qui est député qui était une
des patrons de l'affairé soit à ça les
droits de l'homme on s'est rencontré en
afrique pour bosser sur ces questions là
évidemment on est touché sur ça moi je
suis un de vous dire qu'aujourd'hui le
discours de marine le pen est encore
plus directement il n'est pas réaliste
sur cette question de l'immigration
jeudi que le discours d'eric zemmour est
dur qu'à s'en
sent beaucoup de trace d'humanité et que
ça c'est insupportable que quand on
s'intéresse aux gens on s'intéresse pas
qu'à la france on s'intéresse aux
français et les français les plus
faibles d'entre eux sont en situation
tellement difficile que peut-être qu'on
n'a pas besoin d'en rajouter peut-être
qu'on a besoin de rassurer les gens vous
savez vous sortez de la crise du coc
vide là il ya la guerre qui avait
peut-être besoin de rassurer les gens je
crois qu'ils se trompent qu'ils se
trompent qu'il fait
à un mauvais choix et je dis moi il ya
quinze ans qu'on se connaît quinze ans
que je sais pas s'il faut dire on est
amis on était amis aujourd'hui d'une
part et quant à marine le pen le salon
s'est pas parlé pendant quatre ans au
lendemain de 2010 7 11 ans était
vraiment fâché je pense qu'aujourd'hui
elle fait une meilleure campagne je suis
pas d'accord sur un certain nombre de
chose à laquelle vous vous lavez voulait
avoir commis sur d'autres questions je
suis d'accord avec elle et la politique
peut-être que ce que j'ai appris comme
merci des compromis si j'étais s'il faut
faire campagne que pour quelqu'un avec
qui vous êtes d'accord à 100% vous la
faites pour nous mêmes sinon il ya
toujours des désaccords je pense qu'elle
fait une coupe et une meilleure campagne
2 je pense qu'elle écoute un peu plus l
émoi dans une espèce de tour d'ivoire
vous savez où on a raison sur tout et où
quand tu la critique tu es un traître ou
un paria je pense qu'elle a changé là
dessus pour vous c'est pas des
revirements comme le dit nicolas bay
comme le dit marion maréchal-le pen
elle a changé sur un seul tour des
choses sauf qu'à la différence n'est pas
critique de marines ou que ça va dans le
bon sens
aujourd'hui se dire que je vous prends
une question d'actualité sur la retraite
à 60 ans puisque le chef de l'état peut
vienne l'a proposé à 65 ans marine le
pen vont appeler s'était arrêté à 60 ans
pour tous 21 10 plus tout à fait ça elle
ne dit pas ce que je souhaite qu'elles
disent même dit ce qu'elle veut c'est
être moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut
faire deux choses d'abord il faut
prendre acte l'allongement de la vie de
chacun vous pouvez pas faire comme si ça
n'existait pas c'est ça c'est ça le
discours idéologique se dire on est sur
ce principe là on bouge pas bien sûr
qu'on vieillit qu'on se porte bien plus
longtemps et d'autre part oui il ya un
vrai problème avec des gens qui
commencent à travailler tôt et qui sont
souvent ceux qui font les boulots le
plus difficile pardon quand vous faites
des études en général après tu as la
chance de faire un boulot moins
difficile - physiquement
fatigant et tout est donc il faut
mélanger ces deux choses mais voilà
encore je n'ai pas une position de
principe mais c'est quoi la jeunesse que
65 ans comme le dit emmanuel macron
c'est banal ça ne me choquerait pas si
parallèlement disait que pour ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler le plus jeune
et qui ont les travaux qui ont fait les
travaux les plus pénibles on faisait à
un régime power on adapte et ça a eu ça
me semble une espèce de truc de bon sens
et pas deux ni de droite et de gauche de
bon sens mais d'un seul non c'est pas
tellement réaliste selon vous et cette
proposition de la retraite à 60 ans de
marine le pen c'est joli c'est mieux
c'était avant puisque matin 10 62 ans
alitée 60 ans pour ceux qui commencent
tôt mais je pense qu'elle a fait qu'une
partie du chemin mais je le lui dis ce
que je vous dis là je le lui ai dit
clairement ce qu'est ce que vous croyez
vous croyez à la victoire de marine le
pen au deuxième tour écoutez je l'espère
sinon je la soutiendrai pas ce sera plus
que difficile c'est même plus qu'un trou
de souris pas simplement parce que parce
que à cette droite notre know droite et
a une fois de plus la plus stupide du
monde à se disputer à se déchirer comme
elle est en train de le faire je nie les
3 2 à l'e3 droite si j'ose dire marine
le pen elle valérie pécresse et eric
zemmour pour ça et en plus les trois
aurait dû discuter mais bien sûr vallée
avec la tour disputé vanille faut
arrêter avec cette droite qui se fait
qu'ils qui continue à nous expliquer
qu'il ya une barrière infranchissable
avec des gens comme moi enfin vous
plaisantez je suis moins démocrate que
madame pécresse ou que je sais pas où
tout à l'heure vous agir selon gay avec
qui j'ai moi beaucoup de d'amitié que
j'estime beaucoup vous croyez qu'il ya
de grosses différences vous croyez que
sur 80% des choses on pense pas à peu
près de là de la même façon on va y
avoir des passerelles entre l'ailier sig
s'est pas qui peut il devrait y en avoir
mais vous avez toujours une partie de la
droite vous savez dès qu'on lui dise à
elle se termine mais qu'est ce que va
penser la gauche deux mois qu'est ce
qu'ils vont dire qu'est ce que mon dire
les journalistes qu'est ce que vont dire
les bien pensants qu'est ce que vont
dire les intellectuels non pour se dire
que c'est la gauche qui a établi cette
frontière entre la droite républicaine
et là sur ce poids il a raison enfin oui
il ya des désaccords vous avez compris
moi j'ai des désaccords j'ai aussi les
accords avec madame pécresse mais de mes
deux mains je dire il faut se il faut se
retrouver ça c'est la première grosse
difficulté ces disputes permanente puis
la deuxième difficulté elle est dans le
contexte actuel honnêtement aujourd'hui
le chef de l'état au delà de son mauvais
bilan encore une fois sur l'immigration
et la sécurité notamment un très très
mauvais bilan chez sur lesquels les
questions d'actualité sur le crâne il
fait le job et c'est très difficile de
le critiquer à part de quoi être pro
russe qu'est ce que vous allez choisir
est intouchable en ce moment ça va être
très compliqué c'est l'écouté c'est
évidemment compliqué qu'est ce que vous
voulez dire vous voulez dire qu'il faut
plus discuter avec monsieur poutine vous
allez dire qu'il faut pas faire que en
sorte que l'europe répondent d'une seule
voix vous allez dire que accueillir les
réfugiés c'est pas une bonne chose et
c'est trois choses qui me dit j'ai pas
pour le plaisir de le contredire une des
choses qui me paraissent qui me
paraîtrait qui me paraît juste le
nom ne se pose pas comme ça moi je suis
maire je rejoins personnes je soutiens
marine le pen parce que je suis à sa
double question qui sont importantes
pour moi je pense qu'elle a changé que
les positions qu'elle prend aujourd'hui
même si je n'ai pas la croissance en
sont les bonnes solutions mais en même
temps ça n'empêche pas de recevoir le
chef de l'état dans ma ville quand il
vient d'aller le saluer en dire beaucoup
de bien les paquets et d'en dire
beaucoup de bien et quand sur les pieds
noirs par exemple puisque je suis pieds
noirs il il dit les mots qu'il faut dire
bien sûr je suis d'accord avec lui même
si je suis capable de lui dire et je lui
ai dit que je continue à me rappeler que
cai disait que c'était un crime contre
l'humanité la colonisation s'était des
propos des propos qui n'ont pas de sens
essayons juste d'être raisonnable un
tout petit je reviens simplement sur sur
la stratégie possible au second tour et
sur l'union des droites est ce que au
moins vous pensez qu'une alliance est
possible entre eric zemmour et marine le
pen mais je pense que ça se fera par la
force des choses je pense qu'aujourd'hui
un certain nombre de propos qui ont été
tenus de part et d'autre qui vont rendre
difficile
la grande déclaration d'amour ça va être
un peu difficile et trop loin pour
professionnels
quand des gens vous ont quitté pour
aller chez l'autre camp des propos était
dit en public et puis en public en privé
ça se sait même quand c'est pas le chef
de file qui dit à ses atours de chômer
que les entourages voudra vous qui avez
vous lui dites vous avez des idées vous
avez toujours d'ailleurs des bonnes
relations avec avec les deux alors
peut-être moins avec eric zemmour céder
ces derniers temps ça a été plus calmes
et moi je leur ai proposé vous rappelé
qu'à l'heure actuelle vous continuer
d'essayer de faire le gouvernement dit
oui à un moment donné vous fait vous
rendez compte que vous dites sert pas à
grand chose
attendez je dis moi je pensais que
c'était important pour dire un deux
choses au fond qu'à j'ai voulu les
réunir se répandirent de choses hein dis
dès aujourd'hui que celui qui sera en
tête c'est pour lui que vous voterez et
2 évitez de dire un certain nombre de
choses qui rendent vous savez les
réconciliations c'est comme dans un
couple quand tu te dis 3 saloperies et
que tu te jettes la vaisselle à la
figure t'as pas franchement envie de te
retrouver le lendemain j'aurais dit ça
ils veulent pas nous chasser les ego des
gens passent à peu près avant tout et
j'en suis d'autant plus meurtrie confus
blessés que c'est mes amis qui ne cesse
de dire à juste raison que ce qui compte
avant tout c'est la france si la france
compte avant tout si la france est
menacée comme ils le disent c'est la
civilisation européenne et et est menacé
comme ils le disent à un moment donné tu
t'oublies cinq minutes et tu te dis
qu'est ce qui est bien pour aujourd'hui
pensent plus à eux qu'à la france et en
français aujourd'hui chacun des dd le
gîte à des logiques d'appareils légers
responsabilité quand arnaud une forme
d'irresponsabilité chez eux il ya une
forme d' absence de responsabilité widi
responsabilité quant à la fois tu dis
que la situation est à ce point grave à
ce point grave qu'on ait eu un espèce de
au bord du gouffre et puis faut en tirer
les leçons sur la nécessité à un moment
donné je sais pas moi je la vis dit fin
février la voilà on est début mars celui
qui est qui et dernier pour éviter des
déconvenues devrait se retirer je ne
crois pas là aujourd'hui c'est eric en
l'occurrence qui a 4 5 points de moins
que que marine le pen la responsabilité
ce serait de le dire mais il
ya toujours des ralliements oui mais ça
dit quoi ça dit que aujourd'hui les
ralliements sas a manifestement ça
intéresse peut-être notre petit monde
jeudi est le nôtre la politique les
médias peut être un peu moins les
français
écoutez d'abord la moitié des gens enfin
la moitié des 90 % des gens qui étaient
autour de marion ils sont déjà avec eric
et je pense pas que là que là que la
présence de marion recentre la la
candidature d'éric je pense que c est
exactement exactement le contraire l
attrait le traîne à elle entraîne encore
plus à droite et je ne vois pas de sens
ce dont il a besoin
une question qui s'est posée après le
passage du président a à poissy devant
les parlementaires il a réaffirmé son
souhait de supprimer la redevance télé
est ce que pour vous c'est une bonne
idée ah oui mais moi je suis absolument
pour la suppression de la redevance t
avant même qui le dit je vois surtout
dit mais pour pas que des raisons
d'économie et de pouvoir d'achat pour
les français je le suis aussi parce que
je pense que le service public est trop
trop important qu'on doit le réduire à
quelque chose de 2,2 de plus adapté à
nos démocraties il n'y a pas beaucoup de
pays je suis pas aux états unis me
semble que que la presse est pas une
presse aux ordres de qui que ce soit
même si je suis pas un adepte font
forcément de nez ça tombe de
journalistes non non jamais les deux
journaux américains je pense qu'on
devrait réduire l'audiovisuel public où
il ya je sais pas combien 5 6 chaînes je
pense que on peut faire des économies et
on peut faire faire des économies aux
français en même temps voyez donc je
suis la galerie mais pas exactement pour
les mêmes raisons autre question
dernière question sur ce qui se passe en
corse où les tensions sont vives après
la question devant colin d'astellia une
semaine en prison il ya des violences
tous les soirs avec des blessés du côté
des manifestants du côté des crs même du
côté des journalistes un journaliste a
été baissée est ce que vous comprenez le
silence du gouvernement écoutez je ne
sais pas ce que le gouvernement doit
faire c'est son problème moi ce que je
pense et d'autres choses un évidemment
on peut s'interroger sur le fait que cet
islamiste manifestement dangereux
puissent se retrouver comme ça à croiser
des gens et à les menacer premièrement
deuxièmement je voudrais rappeler comme
ceux colonna a quand même participé si
j'en crois la justice et il a été jugé
donc je suis pas obligé l'employée
inconditionnel il a quand même participé
ou tuer lui-même et je n'en sais je n'en
sais rien je me rappelle plus le procès
exactement pour l'assassinât du préfet
erignac a dressé pas tout à fait rien
troisièmement je ne vais quand même pas
ici trouver des excuses à des gens qui
croient qu'ils rêvent de le feu
il soit une préfecture non non je
comprends l'homme une partie de mes amis
quand c'est du doigt et de leur souhait
d'autonomie et tout ça je peux le
comprendre totalement il y à des
pratiques politiques et des choix qui
sont inadmissibles en plus quand vous
voyez un certain nombre de ces jeunes
c'est qu'ils savent même pas exactement
de quoi qu'ils n'étaient pas là qu'ils
étaient même panier vous avez vu l'âge
ces miliciens et quand vous lui dites ah
mais quand même colonna il a il est
condamné pour avoir tué le préfet
erignac ont chacun pense qu'il veut non
coco chacun on passe pas ce qu'il veut
il ya la justice qui est passée par là
et qui a dit à ses attentes de choses
sur le fait qu'il ait pu être agressée
en prison l'exécutif dit qu'à une
responsabilité de l'état l'exécutif
corse est ce que vous êtes d'accord il
ya une vraie question qu encore une fois
comment ce fait-il que monsieur colonna
se sont retrouvés face à quelqu'un qui
mêle qui était manifestement un
islamiste est manifestement un islamiste
dangereux où il ça il faut répondre à ça
j'espère qu'il y aura une enquête qui
répondre merci robert ménard merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin
[Musique]